tilting at windmills an online stranger
doesn't know you all they have are a few
vague impressions of you too meager to
form anything but a Phantasm so when
they attack you they're really just
attacking their own imagination and
there is no need to take it personally
yeah I mean
when I first joined social media
uh started tweeting in 2016.
I used to get quite upset when I used to
get like nasty comments and stuff you
know like people would say stuff and you
know it would get I believe it in a way
I'd be like you know don't say stuff
about me and I you know they'd call me
like um well I sometimes I'd just be
called a dumb [__] or whatever you know
sometimes people would say that I was a
pseudo-intellectual or whatever and and
back then you know I used to sort of
think okay I must have said something
that was wrong you know for them to to
think that and then I realized after a
while hang on a second I don't know
anybody
who I um engage with online I don't
actually know any of them I don't even
have an idea of who they are really but
I've convinced myself that I know who
they are so therefore I mean the same
must be happening to other people doing
that to me that they couldn't possibly
know who I really are
you know they've only seen
one or two of my posts and then they
built up a personality profile of Me
based on those two posts you know and I
mean we barely know people that we know
in real life you can live with someone
for five years you still don't really
understand who they are and yet we seem
to think that you know we can read one
post by someone or you know watch one
video by that person and immediately we
think that we know that person and this
is a very powerful illusion that
influences I think almost every in fact
I would say that everybody is afflicted
by this delusion
um where we we just get a tiny snippet
of a person's words or their actions
just a tiny snippet and from that we
just build this massive fictional
character in our heads you know from
that skeleton you know I mean I actually
I think I did tweet something along the
lines of that I'll read it out to you
um yeah this was a tweet I recently sent
actually so I read it so it says um you
are a different character in the mind of
each person who knows you because their
impression of you is made of the bones
of what they've seen fleshed out by a
musculature of Pure Imagination
and I think that really sums up what we
do when we see people online where you
know we just have this Bare Bones just
Bare Bones based on a very brief
interaction with someone and then from
that we create this whole fictional
character who
is very real in our minds but doesn't
actually exist outside of our own heads
and that is the person that we level our
criticism at that is the person that we
level Our Praise at and that is a person
that will defend or attack in arguments
and you know will develop all these
theories about this person who doesn't
actually exist
and that happens all of the time and it
happens I realized it was happening to
me you know people were doing that to me
they would say things about me that just
wasn't true like for instance if I wrote
a tweet that criticized the left
people would say that I was right wing
but I'm not right wing at all you know
in fact I'd say that you know I I don't
really have strong political opinions
but I'm probably a Centrist overall
generally I find that you know I agree
with some of the left agree with some of
the right things and just merge them
together but left Wingers when I
criticize the left people assume that
I'm like some Far Right guy and they'll
be like you know they'll write oh you're
a cryptophatic fascist and then if I
criticize the right you know
um then so yeah if I crisis writing
people say I'm a globalist libtard you
know all this stuff like you know I'm a
w e f shill or whatever like you know
there's never been a better time to
insult someone than right now
exactly and I'm just there like you know
before this would have really upset me
you know I'd be like just just from the
fact that it was just because I wasn't
used to it I wasn't used to receiving
all this hate but now when I read I
actually read it with a smile on my face
you know I'm just like because I know
that this person is not actually
attacking me they're attacking their own
imagination yes one uh his maybe a
couple of of interesting
considerations to add in there
this is one of the reasons why audience
capture is so dangerous because the only
way that someone can genuinely Tilt at
windmills is if they have an erroneous
view of who you are really compared with
what they've seen of you online but if
your entire Persona has subsumed the
person and you are playing a role on the
internet quite rightly they're pointing
at the person that you are on the
internet and what you've done is you've
basically become cucked by your own
audience you're now this marionette
that's being played by the algorithm to
the point where you do whatever it asks
of you you feed red meat to the to the
Mob so when someone does point the
finger and say you're a globalist shell
or you're a woke libtard or you're a
right-wing racist or whatever when
someone does say that where is the firm
place for you to stand
where have you got that you can actually
stand if you have sold your soul in
order to gain notoriety online and your
integrity is something that you can't
buy back no matter how much you try and
pay for it
if you've done that where is the you
can't grin when people criticize you
because they're criticizing the
contrived uh monster that you made that
you created yourself into
absolutely and it's a self-reinforcing
feedback loop as well because
like if you're if you're someone like
say um
let's use an example let's use someone
like tinpool for instance Tim Paul was
originally sort of like a kind of anti
uh he was he was an occupied a Wall
Street guy and he was sort of I'd say
quite Progressive it's quite left and he
began to sort of
flirt with some right-leaning ideas and
he developed a right-wing audience and
over time hit the people on the left who
were formerly followers of his they
began to attack him you know saying oh
you're a right-wing chill now you know
you know you're a racist uh sexist
transfer blah blah and so they were
attacking this and what happened was
that Tim began to take this time at
least this is what it appears like to me
I don't know him personally but this is
what it seems like to me
um he seems to have taken that to heart
and he became gradually more and more
right wing uh so I mean I would say he's
probably on right now I don't know if he
would agree with that but based on what
I know of his his content he seems to be
pretty firmly conservative although he
calls himself a liberal his his opinions
don't gel with his self-perception so I
think he's a pretty good idea of
somebody who's succumbed to audience
capture
um he he might still think he's a
liberal but all of his guests pretty
much are people on the right or at best
at the center
um he doesn't really have he doesn't
engage we've left people very often
um you know the only time that I really
remember him doing that in recent
history was uh with Vijaya Gotti uh on
the Joe Rogan podcast uh but generally
he seems to be pretty firmly on the
right he's got his
you know his friends are people like the
quartering who are also sort of somewhat
they call themselves liberal but they're
really more slave to the right
um and I think what's happened is
when left people call people like Temple
out
what happens is this makes him even more
audience captured because he then says
you know I'm a Centrist how could you
call me right when how can you call me a
racist I'm a Centrist and then he'll say
oh no no it's not me who's moved it's
you who've moved you have gone crazy and
not me and so he'll go even further to
the right and say these people are
absolutely crazy they're accusing me of
being racist and you know so it's like a
self-perpetuating cycle and then he
becomes a bit more rowing so then the
left attacking even more saying oh you
know you you're a racist so it just
keeps going on and on and on and you
know it happens I think across the
Spectrum that's just one example I mean
there are probably people who have done
this who've moved leftwards and um you
know they've been attacked by people on
the right uh due to that and then
they've gone even more to the to the
left as a result of that and uh so yeah
it's it's a neutral sort of cycle
symbiosis there's another one that I
think relates to what we've just spoken
about which is the principle of humanity
every single person is exactly what you
would be if you were them this includes
your political opponents so instead of
dismissing them as evil or stupid maybe
seek to understand the circumstances
that led them to their conclusions
yeah so I mean this is again this is
part of why rogeri and rhetoric is so
valuable
because
we don't really have a good idea of
anybody that would be only online you
know uh there are people that I've got
relationships with online who I feel
like I know well but I don't I just
don't because all I've seen is what
they've chosen to show me
and when you when all you've seen is
what people have chosen to show you uh
it there are selection effects to that
and you develop a very distorted idea of
of who they are and this causes you to
have assumptions about people and it can
you know just cause you to have
completely skewed reality
um and the thing so if you really want
to understand who somebody really is
a much better strategy is to try to look
at who how they became who they were put
yourself in their shoes
and to reflect on
their own internal Logic the internal
logic of their own actions
to try to understand because you've got
to bear in mind that everybody does
things that they think are right for
them
you know everybody like every action
that somebody takes they take because
they think it's the right thing to do
even if it's the wrong thing to do they
think it's the right thing to do which
is why they do it so if you can use that
assumption to try to reverse engineer a
person's life experience and find out
why they did the things that they did
then you can develop a much more deeper
understanding than if you simply look at
what they've said online and what
they've done online and you know what's
been said about them or written about
them
these are all going to be things that
are sort of subject to selection effects
you know people are always gonna
comment on the most extraordinary most
wildest wildest things that people have
done they're not going to comment on the
the more mundane things that people do
in their lives you know for every crazy
uh cancelable thought that a person has
they have a thousand opinions that are
just running the mill and mundane yeah
but what happens is that if somebody
says one thing that you don't like you
know you're you're basically just
regard that one thought in that entire
galaxy of thoughts that is their mind
and you'll just you know you use that
one little thought
to just sort of Judge them and to
dismiss them more
to fall in love with them or whatever
you know yeah and so it's much more
important to have a a full holistic
understanding of a person's life because
what they show on online is just nothing
it's it's just it's the tip of the
iceberg you can't see that massive
iceberg that is all of the things that
are motivating them behind the scenes of
offline you know in their life what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]